Hi everyone, in this lesson we're going to go over the outline for this series of videos
as well as look at some optimization lighting concepts.
So let's get started.
So the outline for the scores, first up we'll be looking at lighting optimization.
We'll be analyzing scenes and priority areas as that's very important when it comes to
lighting.
We'll look at baking versus dynamic as a quick overview and then we're going to jump right
in.
So in Lumen we'll look at the Lumen equation overall as in key workflows, limitations,
quality control, optimizing and editing.
Next we'll look at a review of light mass baking.
This includes CPU and GPU workflows.
We'll look at light mass baking CPU review.
We'll set up how to set up a pre-computed lighting scenario review and GPU light mass
review.
Next we'll look at screen space global illumination.
How to use it, when to use it and how to add some things.
Then we'll look at ray tracing as an overall review which will include optimizing for final
pixel review and optimizing for ICV effects to workflows.
And finally last but not least we'll look at optimizing for fog effects.
We get that request a lot.
What to look for and optimizing settings.
With that in mind let's go ahead and get started.
So review, lighting optimization.
Now this is covered in some of the foundational lighting courses but we will be pointing out
a few things specifically for ICV effects and linear workflows.
With some mentions to games because there are some very fundamental principles for both
of these that need to be considered when working with lighting.
So let's go ahead and get started.
So analyzing scenes and priority areas.
The approach.
You need to determine up front if you're using lumen versus ray tracing versus baked lighting.
This is really important because with each type of lighting comes some things you need
to consider.
This can be determined if final pixel is your goal or ICV effects.
Even games also depend on the strength of the machine's running.
And you also need to consider where you're sending your information to.
So are you going to be in the case of games are you packaging it out for mobile or for
iPads.
Are you in the case of ICV effects on a large wall with high performance machines that you're
sending to the via switchboard or are you working with a lower end scene or output and
final pixel.
What kind of GPO are you running when you decide to do and work with your machines.
What is the best approach with those restrictions in mind.
So no lumen is currently available for ICV effects but takes some material and noise overhead.
So you need to consider those things.
Ray tracing is not effective for ICV effects.
But for virtual production you can use it or in the case of final pixel.
If used in games materials are a big part of the performance when it comes to ray tracing
as well as small numerous geo and enclosed areas.
So analyzing the scenes and priority areas.
So your priorities are really important when it comes to ICV effects and virtual production.
You need to make sure that what's important what's up front needs to have the best visual
fidelity and have the highest polys.
So that's kind of the same principle when it comes to games.
So if you're not worried when it comes to final pixel if you're not worried about frame
rate typically.
So ray tracing path tracer or lumen can be used or even a bake method with a combination
of ray tracing at the same time if you wish.
Out of the box unreal legacy baking does a great job.
So ray tracing or lumen may not always be needed.
So just just depends what your visual and you need or want.
The reason why I say that is because each one has a caveat.
If we went to baking our reflections aren't going to be accurate.
If we go to lumen we may find some noise that is persistent a little bit tricky to deal with.
I say the effects lumen in this case is the best approach for instant results and output
when it comes to putting stuff to your wall.
But again you need to consider your materials and you need to consider what you can do to
maybe hide some of that noise that is occurring.
Others will pre bake or use GPU light mass and that also is an option for ICV effects.
GPU baking makes things be a little bit faster if you have to update things on the fly on
set versus CPU baking.
Now we'll talk about the difference between those and it's a bit of review if you've taken
some of the lighting classes but we're definitely going to look at some of those caveats.
So keep those things in mind when you are tackling your scenes.
ICV effects approach having a good idea of the visual concepts ahead of time is key.
A lot of people I find out working with clients and helping people out working in this workflow
trying to get ICV effects or understand the concept of it in the context of Unreal.
A lot of people will still think of Reels like an offline render and throw everything
at it including the kitchen sink.
But it doesn't work like that.
You have to actually work within a real time within real time restrictions.
So again priority areas are key.
Everything in the background can even be put on cards.
So you can make an alpha that's clean and believable maybe even hide some of its impurities with
fog cards or actual fog and you can actually come up with a really nice scene but you got
to be very strategic when you do so.
One thing people need to consider if they are looking at ray tracing it is not path tracing.
In a real time scenario ray tracing is expensive.
Lumion is the best approach for your LED volumes.
So keep those things in mind.
So here's a couple comparisons here of how things are a bit more streamlined and work
better when it comes to lumen versus baking.
For ICV effects the dynamic lighting because all your lights are removable with lumen is
ideal and optimized in 5.3 using level snapshots.
We'll talk a little bit about level snapshots.
We do have classes for that so we're not going to get too deep into it.
They can be used for baking scenarios but they were primarily focused on or can update
correctly better with stationary lights.
Now when you introduce static lighting and you're trying to use level snapshots that's
a little trickier because that bake information doesn't always slide across between each level
snapshot that you made smoothly so it's better to use lumen if you can.
For baking using a blueprint level streaming is an option which we'll briefly talk about
for pre-computed lighting scenarios.
Baked.
That is better to be considered because Unreal can easily snap between them but there is
a limitation where you only get about 3 otherwise you'll hit a GPU cap.
So final pixel approach.
Baking or ray tracing as well as lumen can be used depending on the need.
Ray tracing many times will be used due to the fact that frame rate performance is not
a concern when it comes to final pixel.
So keep that in mind so if you just need a good final product you can turn down by using
it in scaling turn down a bunch of effects and looks and feel and get the raw data you
need then turn it on before you go to your final render and that can actually work pretty
well.
You'll see down below there's a lot of great things you can produce using baked lighting.
All three of these are all baked lighting.
This is the Australian outback sample that we had a while back.
This is the rebirth demo that was done by Quixel before we acquired them and all of them are
all baking.
No ray tracing is involved.
No lumen is involved for it hasn't come around yet and it's straight up baking.
Here's a link if you want to dive in more into these topics and get a better idea about
optimizing.
In the next section we're going to take a look at the lumen equation and have a deep dive
into how to optimize and use lumen to the best of its ability.
Thanks again.